elle porte sur l'état des négociations
européennes concernant l'hydrogène
batarbone celle-ci patine pour le moment
puisque le trilogue prévu hier pour
examiner la directive énergie
renouvelable a été annulée et reporté au
6 mars ce texte fixe des objectifs
ambitieux d'emploi de l'hydrogène dans
l'industrie ce dont on peut se réjouir
mais il prévoit que cette hydrogène
devra être produit à partir
d'électricité renouvelable sans dire un
mot de l'électricité produite à partir
d'énergie nucléaire or si nous ne
pouvons pas utiliser nos réacteurs
nucléaires pour produire de l'hydrogène
la France va avoir beaucoup de mal à
atteindre les objectifs européens
l'Union européenne avait déjà tenté sans
succès d'exclure le nucléaire de la
taxonomie
prohiber l'hydrogène bas carbone permet
aujourd'hui de l'attaquer indirectement
madame la ministre vous avez vivement
réagi en qualifiant cette exclusion de
climaticides et absurde nous ne pouvons
que vous en féliciter car le nucléaire
et l'énergie la moins carbonée dont nous
disposons je note par ailleurs que la
France est loin d'être le seul État
membre frustré par le contenu actuel du
texte aussi je voudrais savoir comment
se présente les négociations sur ce
sujet enfin si la France n’obtient pas
gain de cause serez-vous prêtes à
bloquer la directive énergie
renouvelable pour défendre notre filière
nucléaire et hydrogène je vous remercie